MIKE: Is this yours?
MARK: Yeah, my dad
bought it brand new, '64.
MIKE: No kidding?
MARK: This is my first vehicle.
FRANK: This is what you were
cruising around in high school?
MARK: It is.
MIKE: We're here with
Mark, in Virginia, picking
through his massive collection.
We're finding old electronics,
signs, vending machines,
and everything in between.
[phone ringing]
Ah, this is Peter.
MIKE: Frankie is
bird dogging a boat.
And he is red hot on the trail.
FRANK: Peter?
PETER (ON PHONE): Yes, Frank.
Hey, did you get the
pictures on the boat?
PETER (ON PHONE): I did, indeed.
FRANK: OK.
OK.
So Peter's the man.
He knows when they
were made, how
many there were manufactured--
where, when, what, everything.
I mean, this guy is a
walking encyclopedia
when it comes to boats.
It's a Chrysler flat head.
- Chrysler Flathead.
- 6.
6.
But it's got going
for it, it's been
sitting inside for a while.
And it is a 16-footer.
And it could be done in like
your garage or something,
right?
FRANK: Right.
OK.
When Peter said
$15,000 to restore it--
I mean, that's four times more
than the boat's even worth now.
That is turning
into a big project.
Hey, Peter.
Thanks a lot.
You're the man.
All right, take care.
- Goodbye.
FRANK: Is this something you
would even consider selling?
MARK: Uh-- Frank, from
what he was saying,
I just wouldn't want
to sell it for that.
It's-- it's more
sentimental value to me.
Sure.
MARK: At some point,
I hope I can fix it.
FRANK: Mark says he's going
to get to this project.
They took all the
trim off of it.
They've kept it inside.
And Mark's the kind
of guy to do it.
Because if he had
to farm it out,
it costs more money to fix
it than the whole thing
would be worth.
He kind of just,
basically, described you.
He's like someone
that remembered
the boat, someone that has
an experience with the boat.
FRANK: Time.
MIKE: And so if
you do it yourself,
and you know what you're
doing, then you've
still got room on the back end.
That's right.
FRANK: Sure.
I'm going to keep the boat.
And I'll work on
it with my sons.
You get the van rolling,
get the boat done--
FRANK: Oh yeah.
Oh yeah!
MIKE: And you can pull
the boat behind the van.
FRANK: That'd look great
going down the road.
MARK: That thing
could do a wheelie
in front when you take off.
MIKE: Oh, my gosh.
That'd be cool, wouldn't it?
MARK: I think we can get
it back looking like it did
when-- when my dad bought it.
MIKE: All right.
FRANK: Careful, now.
I didn't get to buy
the boat, you know.
But at the end of
the day, we got
a few nice little pieces here.
You find some mint
Jenson triaxles--
I'll call you.
I'm your man.
FRANK: Give us a call.
MIKE: All right, buddy.
FRANK: All right, take care!
MARL See you guys.
Mike and Frank were very cool.
I'd have them back in a minute.
I might sell Frank some
more of those fuel cans.
[honking]
- Later, Mark!
Bye!
[honking]
[music playing]